ANNOUNCER: Ladies and gentlemen,
the 45th and final President
of the United States.
(applause, cheering)
(camera shutters clicking)
Wow.
(muttering)
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so proud of what
we've accomplished today.
Everyone loved when Obama
killed bin Laden.
And now everyone will remember
where they were
when I freed O.J. Simpson.
Mr. President! Mr. President!
Your party controls
the whole government,
why can't you pass
a health care bill?
It would have passed
if it weren't for the 3 to 5
million illegal senators
who shouldn't have been able
to vote in the first place.
So is your plan now
just to kill Obamacare?
I'm not killing Obamacare.
I'm letting it die naturally.
The same way you let your
grandmother die naturally,
by unplugging her oxygen and
shoving her down the stairs.
Um, is there a theme tonight?
Tonight's theme is
"Made in America."
Because what makes America great
is what America makes.
Whoa!
That's like the first good thing
I've ever said.
We're celebrating the
hardworking Americans
who are making
all kinds of things.
From the lady in the shower cap
who makes honey bunches of oats
to the elves in the tree
who fudge all the stripes.
And, of course, those beautiful
Clydesdale horses
who love beer and hate 9/11.
All such great Americans.
Why did you say it was unfair
for Jeff Sessions to recuse
himself on Russia?
I have a very simple test
for fairness.
Does this thing earn me money,
make me look smart
or arouse me sexually?
If the answer to any of those
is no, totally unfair.
Any comment on
the continuing accusations
that you colluded with Russia?
No, I don't have a comment.
What do I look like? Don, Jr.?
-Kind of, yeah.
-Yes, he's your son, yeah.
Please, Don, Jr. wishes
he looked like this.
Ding.
Folks,
let's not make this into
something ugly like my son.
If I could get rid of him
I would,
but someone's got to go to jail.
I'm the president.
Can you repeal it? Nope.
Let's roll!